with you in Berlin and to celebrate your
50th Anniversary I mean half a century
now of etuk and etuk has contributed
tirelessly during this half of a century
to making Europe a better place
you are the ones who give workers a
voice
you are the ones who have mobilized year
after year and when you walk up the
stairs you can see the different steps
of this journey for fair salaries and
good jobs
you have championed the campaigns for
gender equality and for equal pay
so if Europe has today
the highest labor standards in the world
it is also because of your commitment so
today I do not only want to congratulate
you but I also want to thank you from
the bottom of my heart and not only all
of you here in the room but the many
many thousand trade unionists who are
working day after day on the ground many
things what you have done
[Applause]
now where are we today
we have now since 30 years our single
Market
but we have a very special single Market
it is not simply a market it is a social
market economy and that makes a big
difference so it never had the sole goal
of market efficiency and Market
liberalization
to the contrary
our social market economy functions
because there is the constant dialogue
between the trade unions the employer
associations and the governments so this
is a model that has the well-known
collective bargaining at its core
and that's not a given we should always
keep that in mind
we know that in some parts of the world
the goal of the entire economy is only
to maximize profits pure capitalism
here in Europe
workers and Society must also reap the
benefits we have a clear agreement it is
absolutely okay to make profits but
everyone has to get his or her fair
share
but we also know
that there are other parts in the world
where it's the state that sets the main
economic course or the government or
even worse a party
and that party strives for total control
over businesses and people
and again
we're different
here in the European Union Yes
government set the legal framework under
Democratic control
but social Partners ensure that these
rules then are tailored and matching to
companies and workers needs
the European social market economy is of
course about business and opportunities
but it is a model that at the same time
cares about people
it cares about communities
it is about each and every one of us and
of the society as a whole
so in some
putting people first is the key factor
for the European social market economy
success
so this human-centered approach must
also be our compass in a changing world
we're not only faced with a more
competitive global environment
but also with global warming
smarter Technologies
aging societies just to name a few
and we know that this European success
in this new world is not for granted
but I think we have a good starting
position
thanks to the strong standing of our
companies
our unique single Market
the Innovative power of our research and
science community
the outstanding skills of our workers
Workforce so I believe that there are
huge opportunities that we have to grab
take the clean and the digital economy
it's already bringing countless jobs for
example if you look at the European
battery industry those will need more
800 000 jobs in addition skilled workers
in just the next two years
I'll look at the solar industry
it will need one million more good jobs
skilled workers by 2030 and this is
twice as many
as we have today
and at the same time
we should be very clear that we Face
many challenges
growing automatic automation
the lack of adequate skills for the new
tasks of tomorrow
a global subsidies race
and of course new forms of work for
which the old rules simply don't fit
so our social market economy must keep
Pace with this changing world and that's
where we need you
we need you because the Trade union you
know the workers worries you know
where our rules do not fit anymore are
not fit anymore for purpose and need an
update
you know the proven system of collective
bargaining between strong trade unions
and employers and that is Europe's
Competitive Edge in times of change
because it helps us
to balance both the emerging
opportunities
and the new risks
the economic success but the success for
people
and at the center of this whole action
has to be the individual or to put it in
your own words we are in this together
but we're on this together for fair deal
for workers that must be the goal
[Applause]
first of all I think everyone must get a
fair chance to enter the labor market
we have an unemployment rate of six
percent that's great that's a huge
success that's the lowest level on
record we've never recorded per month in
unemployment rate like this six percent
but
at the same time we have an youth
unemployment of 14
that cannot be
I mean we always say that young people
are our future
so if these young people want to enter
the labor market and they have no chance
14 unemployment
well let's make sure that their future
can begin right away by giving them a
chance them a chance to enter the labor
market and that's why we have created
the youth guarantee
every young European has to get a job
offer every one European has at least to
get a training opportunity we are
complaining about lack of skilled
Personnel well let's just invest
adequately at this in this huge
potential that is out there young people
are our future let's invest in them
[Applause]
my second example
too many women
are forced out of employment when they
choose to have a child
this is just not right
these women
[Applause]
these women are taking on responsibility
and they want to work to earn the income
for their family this is the best that
can happen to our society
these are young people that want to take
responsibility
the economy the economy needs their
skills and we are making their life
difficult what is that so this is why we
introduced the child guarantee we want
that all families can afford child care
and Early Education for their kids that
is empowering parents
it is education for children and it is
skill for our economy this is what the
child guarantee is all about and let's
make it real on the ground important
third Point fairness
fairness is a Cornerstone of our social
market economy
there should not be such thing as
working poverty
everyone who works full-time
should be able to earn a living I think
this is a basic principle of our social
market economy
and therefore my friends I'm so glad
that we took the historic step to pass
the European directive on minimum wages
it is high time
that work pays
and actually work must pay for everyone
for men
and women alike
there is not a single argument why
for the same type of work a woman should
get paid less than a man not a single
argument is out there not a single one
so
[Applause]
that is why we have now the directive on
pay transparency it's a basic trim
principle of equality is finally cause
cast in law equal work deserves equal
pay
my fourth point
during covet
when our streets became empty
our economies came to unhold
our lives were put on hold
that's when we together created the
first ever European short time work
scream scheme I know it is like a
chewing gum a word but the summary says
it all the name is sure the abbreviation
sure
saved millions of European jobs in all
parts and of our Union
and it gave our companies a head start
at the end of the pandemic when the
economy picked up again because those
companies had not laid off their workers
but kept the expertise on the job and
that is the social market economy at her
best in each of every one of these
achievement I was just describing
etok has played a major role and I hope
you are as proud of these achievements
as I am about it
[Applause]
our work is far from over
we are in a fast changing world we must
continue to give protection
while rewarding performance
and this work is particularly
challenging in new sectors
where technology is radically changing
the rules of the game
just think about the massive leaps in
artificial artificial intelligence that
we've seen in the past years alone
of course AI can massively improve the
productivity of companies across the
board
but we have also seen companies using AI
to hire and fire their employees
roughly one quarter 25 percent of
European companies are planning
to use AI tools to support their
recruitment processes
and the same tools can also be used to
automated dismissals
now every algorithm
is designed by a programmer
and this person has a background
and this person has biases
so none of the algorithms is free of
biases and therefore we should be very
very clear no one should be fired
because of an algorithm this cannot be
we need rules
and therefore the answer to the
challenge that AI raises is first of all
a principle
and this principle is called human in
control that must be our underlying
principle for everything
in our proposal on platform work we've
put forward a new set of rules
on the use of automated systems for the
management of platform workers
this means that automated decisions must
be checked by humans
this is a good first step
but algorithms increasingly shape work
Beyond labor platforms
so ladies and gentlemen we are keeping a
very close eye
on the potential need
to regulate regulate the use of
algorithms in The Wider world of work
with the artificial intelligence act for
example we've set clear rules
for high-risk applications of AI
so that companies and programmers can
keep advancing and improving but
citizens and their rights are always
protected this is a minimum of what we
have to do
and finally
all workers deserve a chance to grow
and to progress during their career
we need to create better conditions for
lifelong learning
trade unions have been leading the way
for years on this topic thank you very
much for that
you struck deals with coal mining
businesses
to retrain workers when a mine closes
you've shown that it is possible
you develop Solutions with energy
companies
to train their workers
on new energy sources and energy
efficiencies it is possible
as you said Esther
skills must be treated not as a cost but
as an asset
and that's why we have set for the first
time
a European Target for skills by 2030 we
want to have at least 60 percent of all
adults in training every year
we made 2023
the year of skills and we've launched a
pact for skills
so we are matching companies needs with
the right training for workers to help
millions of Europeans to upskill and
reskill
it was Jack delore who spoke already in
the 1980s
of the right to lifelong training
training so it's high time that we make
it happen by now
dear friends
the basic promise of the social market
economy
is prosperity
while protecting
and empowering workers
it is a promise that our parents and
grandparents built for us
and I want this promise to be true today
for all Europeans for our children and
for our grandchildren
it must be true
for the young women and men who want to
have children and keep advancing in
their career
it must be true
for those who've lost their job
halfway through their career and deserve
a new opportunity
it must be true for those
who have worked for decades
and now wish to retire in dignity this
is the absolute must for as a result for
the social market economy it is the
promise of a fair deal between workers
and employers the core principle of our
social market economy no matter what the
challenge is that awaits us
no matter how fast the world keeps
changing around us
we can and we have to stay true to the
European promise put people first
so thank you for 50 long years of
amazing work hard work and let me wish
you another 50 years at least to come in
the social marketing economy in Europe
thank you very much all the best
[Applause]
thank you
so we need all the women delegates on
stage fast I'm sorry for the guys but we
want all the women delegates on stage
please